[Musique]
on
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
des matins du sénat les missions qui
vous fait vivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée vous allez suivre ce matin
l'audition d'éric lombard le directeur
général de la caisse des dépôts et
consignations cette institution est le
bras financier de la puissance publique
et la caisse des dépôts a un rôle à
jouer dans la relance de l'économie
pendant la crise du coroner virus je
vous laisse écouter cette audition tiens
d'abord à vous remercier madame la
présidente monsieur le président de
m'accueillir ce matin au sénat pour une
audition qui était prévu de longue date
mais je suis très heureux qu'on ait pu
la maintenir malgré les circonstances
tant il est important pour la caisse des
dépôts de présenter ses actions devant
le sénat effectivement nous sommes
placés sous votre protection ainsi que
celle de l'assemblée nationale et c'est
très important pour l'ensemble des
collaboratrices et des collaborateurs de
la caisse des dépôts fait que les
travaux que vous menez vous ont conduit
à auditionner déjà deux mes collègues
important dans le groupe le patron de la
poste et le patron des pays france ainsi
que des collaborateurs en charge du
logement et du tourisme et on y
reviendra
moi ce que je veux vous présenter ce
matin en introduction et j'essayerai
traiter quelques unes des questions que
vous venez de poser matin le président
de monsieur président c'est la stratégie
globale que la caisse conduit dans cette
phase qui repose en fait sur deux axes
d'abord des mesures d'urgence que nous
avons déployés très vite au début de la
crise pour soutenir nos concitoyens pour
soutenir nos entreprises nos territoires
nos institutions
et puis dans un deuxième temps mais nous
y travaillons évidemment dès aujourd'hui
les mesures de relance de notre économie
qui vont être indispensables qui vont
être même vitale et dont je souhaite
vous présenter les grandes lignes et
nous mettrons en oeuvre dès que possible
avant d'aborder ces deux questions et
vous me incité monsieur le président
les mesures que nous préparons sont
rendus possibles par les résultats très
solides enregistrés en 2019 et que j'ai
présenté le 8 avril et qui me donne le
moyen de jouer
le rôle traditionnel de la caisse qui
est un rôle contracyclique savez claque
assénée en 1816 pour gérer déjà le
problème d'un surendettement du pays
liées en l'occurrence aux guerres
napoléoniennes là c'est pas le sujet
mais mais c'est évidemment notre notre
mission le bilan agrégé de la caisse des
dépôts et avant le rapprochement avec la
poste qui s'est opérée effectivement
début mars sections générales et fonde
épargne s'élève pour être précis à 459
milliards d'euros adossé à des fonds
propres qui à la fin de l'année 2019 se
montait à 54 milliards d'euros dont 42
milliards au titre de la section
générale et 12 milliards au titre des
fonds d'épargné donc force de frappe
financière importante et qui a dégagé en
2010 9,1 résultats agrégés de 2,7
milliards qui se partage en deux
milliards d'euros pour la section
générale et ce chiffre est en hausse de
300 millions par rapport à l'année 2018
du fait notamment de la bonne tenue
alors c'est maintenant l'histoire des
marchés financiers et puis de
l'accélération de la rotation de notre
portefeuille notamment dans la banque
des territoires est en revanche une
baisse des résultats du fonds d'épargné
à 700 millions d'euros qui s'explique en
fait par plusieurs facteurs d'abord
l'impact de l'inflation sans être trop
de technique mais comme les fonds
d'épargné serbe naturellement
[Musique]
l'intérêt versé au titre du livret a et
l'inflation est un des éléments du
calcul de ce taux
nous avons à l'actif une protection
contre l'inflation avec de l'ordre de 30
milliards d'euros d'obligations indexées
sur l'inflation l'inflation était plus
faible qu'anticipé est très faible
l'année dernière au mois d'octobre qui
est le moment où on prend en compte le
taux d'infection et ça s'est traduit par
une baisse de plusieurs centaines de
millions de nos revenus
deuxième sujet le deuxième plan logement
ou un soutien au secteur de l'ordre de
50 millions enfin pas de l'ordre de 50
millions d'euros par an pendant trois
ans a été décidé et qui était
provisionner intégralement sur les
comptes de l'année 2019 donc 150
millions et puis enfin une légère hausse
du coût de l'accessibilité bancaire
versées par les fonds d'épargné à la
banque postale et c'est tout cela donc
des décisions enfin un effet marché et
de décision prise conjointement avec les
pouvoirs publics qui se traduisent par
cette baisse du résultat des fonds
d'épargné
alors ces résultats nous ont permis de
verser à l'état un milliard quatre de
rappeler monsieur le président près d'un
milliard cent au titre de la
contribution du versement entre
guillemets volontaires la règle actuelle
est temps que nous versons la moitié des
résultats consolidés à l'état et une
contribution relative représentative de
l'impôt sur les sociétés de 368 millions
pourquoi en forte hausse alors c'est des
raisons purement techniques parce que là
on applique vraiment le code des impôts
en 2018
il y avait eu somme de provisions à
passer sur des titres qui s'impliquent
dirait qu'ils s'impliquent directement
sur leur état fiscales qui ont été
reprises en 2019 et c'est ça qui
explique une augmentation de la crise
donc c'est vraiment à la fois très
technique et sur un segment du
portefeuille d'investissements très très
particulier mais voilà c'est
l'application des règles alors
effectivement la somme de tous a conduit
art et un résultat un petit peu
inférieur à celui qui a été versé
l'année dernière puisque on a un effet
au titre du versement de la section
générale alors par ailleurs
effectivement l'état a renoncé pour sa
part et c'est ça qui explique la baisse
par rapport à l'année d'avant également
à la contribution au versement au titre
des fonds d'épargné qui était prévu à
363 millions d'euros
pourquoi est ce que l'état opérer ce
renoncement parce que la situation de
solvabilité des fonds d'épargné et
disons plus difficile en ce moment
d'une part parce que la baisse des
marchés financiers impacte les deux
bilans mais nous avons ça s'est
construit comme ça depuis l'origine
moins de marge sur nos fonds propres sur
les fonds d'épargné et donc l'état a
souhaité renforcer les fonds propres
en opérant pas ce versement et nous
attendons surtout en 2020 une année qui
va être difficile pour les fonds
d'épargné pour deux raisons qui dont
l'une s'appliquait déjà en 2019
c'est que on attend au mois d'octobre au
moment où calculera l'inflation qui
permet de calculer la rémunération de
notre portefeuille d'obligations
adossées sur actions surimpression
pardon d'avoir une inflation très très
faible très faible et donc à nouveau
nous aurons peu de revenus de cette
partie du portefeuille et par ailleurs
la baisse des marchés financiers
notamment des marchés actions va se
traduire par une baisse de la solidité
des fonds d' épargne donc en
anticipation l'état a décidé de ne pas
faire ce versement pour protéger la
solidité des fonds d'épargné
donc tout ça s'explique s'explique je
crois très bien malgré tout et malgré la
crise qui nous frappe depuis maintenant
plus de deux mois et notamment la baisse
des marchés financiers tout cela appuyé
sur les brutes à 2019 et la solidité de
notre bilan
d'aubert pas ou très marginalement dans
marge de manoeuvre et nous avons les
moyens la capacité de contribuer à la
fois la protection et au redressement
notre économie
et à faire ce qui est notre mission
historique de soutenir l'économie et
soutenir sa la transformation et c'est
maintenant ce que je vais vous présenter
rapidement
d'abord je perds mais devant vous de
rendre hommage à l'ensemble des
collaborateurs de la maison qui depuis
le premier jour de la crise sont au
travail pour que toutes les missions
soient remplies en fait comme beaucoup
d'institutions et d'entreprises
les collaborateurs de la caisse se sont
mis en télétravail la direction générale
d'ailleurs c'est une démo mise en
télétravail et 85% de nos 6000
collaborateurs étaient connectés sac
chaque jour et la transformation
numérique puissante que nous avons
accéléré depuis deux ans et demi avec
olivier sichel a permis ce
fonctionnement normal on a même réuni
des comités à plusieurs dizaines de
personnes par notre organisation interne
les réseaux ont tenu et nous ont permis
de travailler notamment normalement et
d'être en connexion avec nos partenaires
et avec eux la place quelques exemples
de cette continuité savait que la caisse
des dépôts gère la retraite d'un
français sur cinq
le versement des retraites s'est fait en
bon ordre
selon le calendrier et les modalités
habituelles et un sujet plus complexes
qui sont les versions qui se font par
traitement manuel parce que c'est des
cas typiques
malheureusement l'augmentation de la
mortalité s'est traduit par une
augmentation des inversions que nous
avons subies et les équipes ont réussi à
récupérer le courrier et à traiter à
distance les versions pour que la
situation difficile des personnes
touchées naturellement par par un deuil
ne soit pas obérées par la situation est
d'ailleurs je pense que vous n'avez pas
entendu parler ce qui prouve que ça
s'est passé tout à fait normalement on a
continué nos efforts en matière de
formation professionnelle avec le
développement de mon coin de formation
qui opportunément a été lancée de façon
digitale ou mot novembre sous l'autorité
de la ministre
muriel pénicaud le paiement des
organismes de formation c'est fait et
bizarrement la demande de formation à
distance s'est accrue voilà et
naturellement nous avons pu y répondre
on a dans la période lancer une nouvelle
plate forme qui se fait à l'initiative
de la secrétaire d'état se fit cluzel et
de la scène et ça mon parcours handicap
accessible à tous
millions de personnes en situation de
handicap et de leurs profs et cela on
l'a fait malgré la situation et ça c'est
très apprécié évidemment par les
personnes concernées
transdev à opérer ses missions de
service public sur l'ensemble du
territoire
la cnr a continué à produire de
l'électricité et puis je dirais pour
terminer parce que nous en sommes
également très très fier les prestations
sociales financée largement par la
caisse qui a contribué au financement de
l'acoss et distribué notamment dans le
réseau de la poste et de la banque
postale ont été versés fin mars
fin avril et les prestations
exceptionnelles du 15 mai de façon
normale avec un petit peu plus de queue
au guichet parce qu'il ya un petit peu
moins de monde d'une part et parce qu'il
y avait la mesure d'une distanciation
social mais ses prestations sont arrivés
à un moment où c'était évidemment très
important et encore plus pour nos
concitoyens les plus défavorisés alors
parallèlement on a lancé tout un tas de
mesures de soutien massif aux
entreprises et à notre économie est le
premier sujet a été de régler les
problèmes de trésorerie puisque c'est ça
qui frappe en premier et bpi france a
mis en place que nicolas dufourcq a
appelé un un pont aérien de cash permis
par le programme mis en place par le
gouvernement de prêts garantis par
l'état qui sont opérés par bp france est
distribué par les réseaux bancaires
je peux vous donner le chiffre d'hier
soir 73 milliards d'euros de prêts
garantis ont été prêts accordés 73
milliards à 440 mille entreprises
quatre cent quarante mille entreprises
donc cette protection de première ligne
qui a été mise en place de façon très
rapide à fonctionner dans le même temps
l'ensemble des filiales immobilières de
la caisse se sont engagés à soulager les
charges locatives des commerces de
proximité
la caisse des dépôts icade cdc habitat
ont renoncé aux loyers du deuxième
trimestre pour les entreprises de moins
de dix salariés afin de protéger ce
tissu d'entreprises de proximité
et puis la banque des territoires à
accompagner également évidemment ses
partenaires
de l'ensemble des territoires territoire
avec nos 16 directions régionales et aux
35 implantation territoriale qui étaient
sur le pont qui sont sur le point qui
vont continuer à l'être il ya une
initiative dont nous sommes très fiers
de l'avoir soutenu qui a été prise avec
les régions qu'on appelait les fonds
résilience alors qu'ils peuvent avoir
des noms différents dans certains pays
centre val de loire souhaité appeler son
fonds renaissance pour des raisons qu'on
peut comprendre nous abondons de façon
égalitaire ces fonds à hauteur de 2
euros par habitant des régions à parité
avec les régions et pour soutenir les
entités économiques les plus petites les
associations les très petites
entreprises qui ne sont pas couverts par
le dispositif bpi france que je viens de
rappeler
donc c'est font naturellement ne se font
que quand les régions le souhaite mais
nous avons déjà ouvert et lancé des
fonds de ce type avec la région grand
est qui a été l'initiatrice de ce type
de fonds les pays de loire la région sud
la nouvelle aquitaine auvergne rhône
alpes la bretagne
l'occitanie la bourgogne franche comté
centre val de loire je m'en dire un mot
la normandie la corse la réunion la
guadeloupe et la nouvelle calédonie si
notre engagement dans ses fonds à ce
jour atteint 90 millions d'euros ils
sont extraordinairement utilisées par
les opérateurs des régions et nous
sommes d'ailleurs en train de regarder
si des fonds européens peuvent compléter
pour continuer à répondre à la demande
qui est très forte ce qui traduit
d'ailleurs la détresse de ce tissu
économique
j'en ai dit en parlant des prestations
sociales nous sommes le banquier de
l'acoss on a contribué à sécuriser dans
l'urgence la sécurité de systèmes de
protection sociale puisque les
cotisations ne rentre pas et dont nous
avons approuvé sous l'autorité de la
commission de surveillance une
augmentation de 10 milliards d'euros de
nos prêts à la cause qui atteignent 21
milliards d'euros donc une contribution
très importante
nous sommes comme vous le savez le
métier du service public de la justice
donc on a ouvert une enveloppe de 90
millions d'euros pour assurer le report
sur simple demande des prêts accordés
aux offices des notaires et une autre
enveloppe de 500 millions d'euros pour
financer leur charge
nous avons à ce jour reçu 1500 demandes
d'accompagnement des notaires et puis
vous avez dit un mot du secteur du
logement social sur lequel nous ne
voyons pas trop de tension aujourd'hui
sur la liquidité mais pour être certain
que il n'y en ait pas nous avons
réactivé une ligne de trésorerie de 2
milliards d'euros et nous sommes
naturellement un dialogue très étroits
avec les acteurs et puis la mise en
place du deuxième volet du plan logement
se poursuit pour les organismes qui ont
un décalage de recettes du fait de
problèmes de voiliers ou autre
naturellement nous avons opéré un report
des échéances de prêts longs termes sur
leurs demandes dont nous sommes vraiment
très attentifs à cela et tout cela se
fait de façon très rapide et très simple
puisque l'intégralité du financement du
logement social se fait par une
plateforme digitale qui j'utilise dont
ils ont l'habitude et qui permet de
gérer tout ça simplement où c'est
évidemment mobilisé pour soutenir le
secteur des entreprises publiques
locales et qui sont très importantes
pour nous comme le sont je suis certain
pour vous c'est un levier privilégié de
notre action sur les territoires elle
bénéficie de report des chances de près
de 1000 de trésorerie spécifique et plus
particulièrement on à financer
l'intégralité des études dites flash qui
permettent de faire des analyses rapides
de leur situation économique et
éventuellement des mesures de
redressement qui sont nécessaires toutes
ces actions se font dans une coopération
renforcée avec nos partenaires européens
et internationaux dans tous les pays
européens les acteurs publics
réfléchissent au rôle qu'ils ont à jouer
et nous avons nous avons voulu resserrer
le lien étroit que nous avons avec nos
homologues
on a eu notamment une réunion avec les
cinq avec les quatre autres grandes
banques publiques de développement
européennes celles d'allemagne de
pologne d'italie et d'espagne
le sens des aiguilles d'une montre ainsi
qu'avec le président de la banque
européenne d'investissement pour voir
comment coopérer et nous avons une
réunion pour relancer notre coopération
avec la banque européenne
d'investissement qui va jouer un rôle et
vous avez vu les annonces faites
d'ailleurs il ya hier je crois par le
prénom république et la chancelière
d'allemagne
et puis notre lien historique avec les
caisses africaine se poursuit l'afrique
va être très touchés j'étais d'ailleurs
moi-même en côte d'ivoire au début du
mois de mars juste avant le confinement
pour appuyer le développement de notre
petite soeur ivoirienne qui va jouer un
rôle important
alors pour passer à la perspective qui
s'ouvre à nous dès lors qu on est en
train a naturellement continûment
d'assurer ce rôle de filets de sécurité
un autre économie avec les outils que
nous avons
comment est-ce qu'on se projette dans
une phase qui va demander une puissante
relance de l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques notamment des acteurs
publics parce que les conséquences
économiques de cette crise sanitaire
malheureusement sont pour l'essentiel
devant nous on travaille pour que la
reprise économique soit la plus rapide
et la plus saine possible et le sujet va
être un sujet de fonds propres et de
trouver la façon d'allouer les fonds
propres à notre économie pour protéger
et permettre cette relance et de le
faire rapidement de le faire le plus
rapidement possible alors ça va
s'appuyer sur l'ensemble de nos moyens
et notamment sur la mobilisation de
l'épargné populaire protéger l'épargné
des français et l'utiliser pour nos
missions d'intérêt général c'est notre
adn depuis deux cent quatre ans et c'est
ça que nous allons faire dans les mois
qui viennent d'autant que ce n'était pas
elle n'a jamais été aussi abondante ce
qui n'est pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle les français ont épargné parce
qu'il ne pouvait pas dépenser et cette
absence de dépenses naturellement pèsent
sur l'économie
aujourd'hui l'épargné des français
nous l'estimons à 40 % de leurs revenus
et je peux vous dire
ce chiffre je crois va être communiqué
dans les heures qui viennent que au mois
d'avril la collecte nette sur le livret
a et le ldd s a atteint un niveau jamais
atteint depuis la précédente crise
d'ailleurs pour un mois d'avril à 7,4
milliards d'euros de collecte nette 7
milliards au mois d'avril
c'est à dire trois fois plus qu'au mois
d'avril de l'année 2019
voilà c'est un indicateur de la
situation de notre pays et cette épargne
je pense que le plus tôt elle ressortira
de nos livres pour financer la
consommation et l'investissement le
mieux ce sera mais dans l'intervalle je
peux aussi vous dire que cette épargne
ne dort pas c'était pas ne dort pas elle
est pleinement utilisés pour le soutien
de notre économie l'activité de
financement du logement social se
poursuit l'activité de financement des
collectivités locales a augmenté
elles sont importantes c'est évident est
de plus en plus nous allons l'utiliser
d'ailleurs nous sommes très favorables à
l'idée que ces fonds d'épargné dont
l'encours s'accroît de fait cette
collecte que l'utilisation de ces fonds
puissent être élargies pour être plus
utile et plus efficace en cette période
de sortie de crise
alors notre rôle contracyclique s'est
pas seulement les fonds d'épargné
naturellement c'est aussi notre
portefeuille financier qui a porté par
les fonds d'épargné par la section
générale sommes le premier investisseur
institutionnel au capital des
entreprises cotées ce qui nous donne une
responsabilité et dans cette période
naturellement nous avons non seulement
continuer à acheter des actions et des
obligations émises par des entreprises
françaises
mais nous avons un peu accéléré
notamment début de la période
notre programme d'achat c'est notre rôle
habituel nous investissons nos fonds
mais nous avons aussi un rôle de place
et vous l'avez notamment évoqué
monsieur le président un rôle de
mobilisation des acteurs privés et
effectivement je veux vous dire du
programme d'investissement je vous dire
à vos du programme d'investissement que
nous avons initié avec les compagnies
d'assurance en complément du programme
initié en 2012 qui s'appelle le qui
s'appelait effectivement le programme
neuf
les assureurs vont contribuer à hauteur
de 1,7 milliard d'euros et la caisse des
dépôts à hauteur de 100 millions d'euros
que nous allons mettre ce programme il
va se déployer autour de trois axes
d'abord les fonds généralistes qui
existaient déjà et c'est la vertu de ce
programme c'est qu'on peut aller très
vite puisque il ya déjà des fonds qui
sont engagés avec des gérants qui sont à
la manoeuvre et à qui on va apporter ces
fonds nouveaux essais font ces deux va
pour les actions cotées ne vit pour une
stratégie mixte cotées et non cotées
nouveau pour de la dette de ses
entreprises et ses finances des deux
pays et sa finance à la fois odette et
aux fonds propres
comme je les dis et puis on va créer des
nouveaux fonds avec des nouveaux
gestionnaires sur lequel les appels
d'offres pour les sélectionnés sont en
cours avec notamment deux axes nous
souhaitons que 40% des fonds soient
dédiés des fonds levés soient dédiés à
deux secteurs spécifiques la santé des
raisons évidentes les investissements à
long terme la capacité de production en
europe les laboratoires l'innovation at
les start up
donc il ya là un segment sur lequel les
finances seront à disposition rapidement
évidemment le tourisme dont je leur
dirai un mot en parlant du plan tourisme
mais une partie de ces fonds vont être
fléché vers les entreprises du tourisme
afin de maximiser notre impact sur les
territoires et c'est une préoccupation
dont je certain que nous la partageons
on va aussi renforcer notre action dans
des grands programmes d'action
territorial et je pense à l'action coeur
de ville qui de mon point de vue était
un succès naissant un peu handicapé par
le report des élections municipales mais
je m'aventure au delà de la condition
mais que nous souhaitons
continuer et renforcer puisqu'on à la
222 ville où habite un quart des
français et donc c'est important de
continuer ses programmes et puis le le
plan territoire d'industrie qui va être
un des éléments importants de la
relocalisation dont vous avez parlé
l'une et l'autre on a un président de
monsieur le président effectivement pour
faire revenir en france
des filières industrielles dont on voit
bien que au delà des raisons économiques
a aussi des raisons de souveraineté qui
doivent nous conduire à les relocaliser
et là on travaille conjointement et bpi
france la caisse des dépôts la banque
des territoires en finançant les
infrastructures et les collectivités
locales et les payeurs france les
entreprises dans leur implantation et
dans leurs plans et puis le plan
d'investissements d'avenir qui nous
semble-t-il on a commencé pendant la
séquence à y travailler avec le
secrétaire général au plan
d'investissement qui doit réfléchir aux
principales filières sur lequel nous
nous pourrons nous pourrons investir
alors les quatre secteurs prioritaires
d'intervention de la banque des
territoires dans cette phase qui s'ouvre
devant nous sont sont les suivants et ça
permettra de répondre déjà aux questions
que vous avez évoqué le premier c'est
logement et l'habitat
la relance du secteur est crucial pour
notre économie est effectivement céder
ses habitats annoncé un appel à projets
pour quarante mille logements il me
semblait que c'était une contribution
qui serait importante 32 mille logements
ont déjà fait l'objet de pré réservation
des ponts d'auteur donc ce plan va se
mettre en place rapidement il va
soutenir d'ailleurs l'activité du
bâtiment et des travaux publics
localement et puis permettent de loger
nos concitoyens et puis naturellement
les plans logement 1 et 2 auquel nous
contribuons puissamment vont continuer à
se mettre en place et notamment vous
souvenez que l'année dernière on a mis
en place un programme de prêts
participatifs de 800 millions d'euros
sur lequel la demande est forte qui sont
des prêts sont à des conditions
avantageuses pour les bailleurs et qui
vont être mis en place en essayant de
les flécher sur des bailleurs qui
construisent et qui investissent c'est
pas un plan de soutien à leur trésorerie
deuxième secteur essentiel la santé le
médico social ou joue un rôle
structurant
vous avez parlé de l'asf il lasse fil
sur lequel nous sommes en train de
finaliser les travaux techniques pour
que l'opération de rapprochement se
passe effectivement moment elle n'est
pas finalisé j'espère qu'elle pourra
s'utiliser avant l'été la sfi les uns
des financeurs important du secteur des
hôpitaux publics et va continuer à
l'être avec la banque postale
et puis 4 santé qui a un investisseur
important du secteur ainsi que haarp
avis qui est un réseau d pad dont nous
sommes proches et que nous finançons
nous allons participer à la
restructuration de leur dette au
financement de la réhabilitation des
bâtiments au financement d'équipements
structurants des plateaux techniques
pour que cet effort magnifique que fait
le pays qui a fait le secteur
hospitalier qu'on fait des ehpad puisse
être appuyé par des investissements afin
que cet effort soit soient poursuivis et
enrichie et puis on voit bien que la
numérisation du secteur est un enjeu est
peut être un des éléments de réponse
quand on voit le développement de la
télémédecine et je pourrai revenir s'il
ya des questions sur la contribution
massive que nous jouons sur le maillage
en très haut débit du territoire
mais ça ça va permettre le développement
de la mède télémédecine qui a pris un
essor énorme depuis deux mois parce que
par nécessité parce que les gens peuvent
pas se déplacer
mais pour les personnes qui sont venues
à domicile c'est certainement une bonne
réponse troisième secteurs le tourisme
deux millions d'emplois une puissance du
pime tout le monde connaît ces chiffres
aujourd'hui une situation critique
j'ai eu le
l'honneur de participer au comité
international du tourisme présidée par
le premier ministre
vendredi dernier nous avons décidé de
mobiliser véritablement un plan marshall
pour le tourisme nous allons mobiliser
groupe caisse des dépôts 1 3 milliard
d'euros de fonds propres en soutien du
tourisme avec une kyrielle de fonds afin
que l'ensemble des secteurs et
l'ensemble des tailles d'entreprises
soient couvertes
notre préoccupation naturellement les
grands opérateurs doivent être soutenus
et le seront mais ils ont nos numéros de
téléphone et ce bercy notre souci est
que les petits opérateurs et même les
très petits opérateurs les restaurants
dans les villes moyennes ou petites
on parlait avec ceux de montgolfier 2d
des sites touristiques doivent être
soutenus également et ça ça demande un
maillage très fin et donc il ya toute
une série de fonds qui vont répondre à
tout cela avec un site qui est en place
et qui permet aux différents acteurs de
savoir à qui ils doivent s'adresser
puisqu'une fois très opérationnelle là
dedans pour avoir les financements dont
ils ont besoin et qui vont les aider
on va chercher dans ce mouvement dans
tout mouvement de sortie de crise à ce
que nous financions des opérateurs
qu'ils soient plus inclusif et sensible
aux côtés de développement durable
rénover un hôtel si en plus on peut à
rénover améliorer l'isolation thermique
c'est encore mieux et ce sera l'occasion
de le faire les objectifs
environnementaux je les ai pas évoqué on
les perd jamais de vue et ils devront
être très très présent dans cette phase
j'en viens au quatrième secteur
justement c'est l'arrêt la transition
écologique énergétique et je
souhaiterais affirmer ici une conviction
profonde dont je suis sûre qu'elle était
déjà exprimée par nicolas dufour la
banque du climat en france c'est
l'action de bpi france et de la vendée
territoire donc du groupe caisse des
dépôts
nous avons prévu consacrer 20 milliards
d'euros entre le capital et les
financements à ce segment sur sur les
années qui viennent pour pour que cette
transition soit accéléré faire levier
pour que les entreprises se dotent d'une
stratégie climat ambitieuse
et puis aussi puisque nous sommes un
investisseur institutionnel important
avec nos plus de 250 milliards d'euros
d'investissements en tant qu'actionnaire
faire pression sur les entreprises pour
qu'elles accélèrent leur transition
climatique et procéder à la
décarbonation du portefeuille
on s'était engagé en 2014 réduire notre
empreinte carbone de 20%
on a atteint l'objectif plutôt prévu et
on doit aller le plus vite possible de
la vère la neutralité carbone
de même que tous nos investissements se
met maintenant dans un scénario de
limitation du réchauffement climatique à
1,5 degré et nous savons combien cet
objectif est ambitieux mais il doit être
atteint et puis enfin on s'est doté une
feuille de route en faveur de la
biodiversité avec cinq de nos filiales
pika d'egis la compagnie des alpes la
société forestière et cdc biodiversité
pour respecter les dix principes de la
plateforme entreprises engagées pour la
nature et mesurer l'impact de nos
activités sur la nature on voit bien que
le recul de la biodiversité et peut-être
hypothèse débattue par les scientifiques
une des raisons du développement des
pandémies depuis plusieurs années voilà
la question de la bombe du climat de la
transition écologique énergétique
elle doit irriguer l'ensemble de nos
actions l'ensemble de nos actions
puisque l'enjeu et des cif est en
réalité les efforts que nous avons faits
pour lutter contre cette pandémie
si on pouvait avoir des efforts de même
envergure pour lutter contre le
changement climatique je pense que on
serait dans la bonne direction
je veux pas être plus longs dans cette
introduction peut-être les déjà été trop
mais j'essaie de découvrir au passage
sur des questions qui ont été évoquées
je suis à votre
disposition est encore une fois très
heureux d'être dans ce dialogue avec
vous je vous remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le directeur général
d'alors en accord avec sophie primas on
va faire alterner les interrogations par
les membres de nos deux commissions et
on va commencer si vous le voulez bien
avec albéric de montgolfier le
rapporteur général du budget merci
monsieur le directeur général moi je
fais un parallèle avec 2009 2009 par
georges tournay il y avait 2 philippe
qui était là il y avait philippe adnot
philippe dallier que d autres émissions
j'étais aussi dans cette commission je
sais pas qui étaient ces produits on en
a quelques souvenirs donc la crise
n'était pas il ya peut-être d'autres de
la même ampleur ilham nature mais
néanmoins il y avait eu à l'époque deux
participations de la caisse des dépôts
plan de relance il y en avait une qui
portait sur des prêts aux collectivités
et 5 milliards d'euros à l'époque pour
des prêts aux collectivités
territoriales j'ai pas si on a un bilan
à tirer ici à d'ores et déjà des
dispositions qui sont prévus pour aider
les collectivités qui aura dans des
situations compliquées
et puis il y avait une mobilisation
importante des fonds d'épargné qui avait
permis de financer à l'époque 23
milliards d'euros de prêts à des pme est
donc aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit on peut
vers le voir le verre à moitié vide ou à
moitié plein la collecte de l'épargné
est une mauvaise nouvelle parce qu'elle
s'est débattue domaine d'érosion sur la
consommation notamment les niveaux sont
très élevés c'est aussi peut être une
bonne nouvelle dans la mesure cela
laisse des marges de manoeuvre si on est
capable de libérer
c'était pas renié est la question que
vous posez c'est est-ce que ce surcroît
d'epargne peut servir à d'autres usages
que le logement social on a un sujet
cette année est ce que d'alliés pour en
parler plus que moi est ce qu'on va
construire
on est prêt même des exécutifs locaux
sis a pas de permis de construire
s'il n'y a pas de mercy a pas de
plus président de bci et des procédures
qui sont arrêtés ça va être très
compliqué d'avoir beaucoup de familles
construire cette année donc même si vous
leur donnez il ya un plan de relance
construction de trente quatre mille
logements
c'est plutôt ce qui m'inquiète c'est
plutôt les délais entre le moment prend
la décision est effectivement la
construction va démarrer on est sur des
rats sans doute des questions des dames
et d'accélération des procédures comme
on avait su le faire en 2009
c'est ce que relève non budgétaires du
dvd l'époque des ordonnances ou des
dispositions qui avaient permis de
réaccélération nombre de procédures
administratives
mais au-delà de ça on va voir une année
sans doute de faible consommation en
termes de besoins de logement social
locaux comme le recrutement je me ce
sera ma seule question comment orienter
cette épargne vers la consommation est
passablement les importations de
téléphones chinois mais d'autres
dispositions donc ils peuvent balayer
des besoins importants dans le bâtiment
la rénovation énergétique des logements
des particuliers
est ce que c'est une piste elle qu'on
peut aller vers des sectes vers d'autres
formes de logement qui soit pas
exclusivement la construction de
logement social et puis globalement
est-ce que ça doit être utilisée pour
d'autres usages permettant de financer
également les investissements des pme
voilà c'est aujourd'hui le sujet
sur lequel dans ce flot de mauvaises
nouvelles on a peut-être en effet de
mauvais mauvais signal mais ça ne laisse
quelques marges de manoeuvre si on est
capable de mobiliser
c'était par n'y est ce qu'il faut aller
glisser et puis que vous serez vous
est-ce qu'il faut créer un nouveau
produit d'épargné rigueur proposé un un
copain
c'est mais je pas sûr que le terme d'un
plan d on a envie de se créer un plan
que vides je passe une bonne idée mais
c'est ce qu'ils proposaient bon voilà
est ce que il est peut-être est-ce que
si on pourra créer propose un produit
d'épargné orientés vers la santé par
exemple
c'est une mauvaise idée est-ce que ça
fait une moyenne voilà donc c'est la
question c'est ça c'était les vraies
questions sur quoi dans les pannes
faut-il changer les usages du livret a
faut-il une nouvelle forme de livret
d'epargne pointer les pannes et comment
concrètement réussir à ce que c'était
pas y aller la consommation et à
l'investissement
beaucoup d'intervenants inscrits michel
raison
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le le directeur général merci
pour toutes vos explications vous avez
parlé entre autres du plan marshall
tourisme
vous avez répondu en partie à la
question que je souhaitais vous poser
mais je vais là la compléter sur les 500
millions de ressources du groupe que
vous dirigez préciser un peu plus les
les orientations dont vous avez dit
qu'il y aurait évidemment pas clé des
grosses structures mais les petites et
vous savez que tout le monde
souhaiterait dans notre pays
un aménagement du territoire plus
prononcé et en matière d'aménagement du
territoire
on souffre tous de cette fameuse règle
des 80 20 qui n'est pas facile à
résoudre
et il existe aussi dans le tourisme et
est-ce que vous avez avec vos
partenaires parce que évidemment c'est
pas vous tout seul surtout qu' on n'a
pas de reproche à faire la caisse des
dépôts qui est présente vraiment
présente dans tous les territoires mais
qui accompagne mais parfois
l'accompagnement ne suffit pas il y à
des leviers à utiliser pour inverser
certaines tendances
donc on souhaiterait voir inverser cette
tendance du 20 % de touristes dans 80%
du territoire et 80%
les 80 % qui sont pas pourvus donc
qu'est-ce que vous avez quelques idées
sur ce sujet sur les 1 milliard 3 en
fonds propres quelles sont vos
principales cibles pour l'utilisation de
5 milliards 3 vous avez aussi parlé de
l'orientation en matière de tourisme
plus durable dans tous les secteurs
économiques ou moins économique on parle
de développement durable
mais où est le curseur car comme dans le
domaine agricole entre ceux qui
souhaiteraient que le fromage ne soit
vendu qu'aux voisins et cultivé que avec
l'eau de pluie et quelques prières en
matière de tourisme ya aussi ceux qui
souhaiteraient voir plus d'avions du
tout et que le touriste puissent aller
dans le village voisin dans le jardin du
du paysan du village voisin
ça c'est des extrêmes donc entre les
extrêmes de cela et de ceux qui
voudraient ne rien voir changer du tout
que avec lesquels je ne suis pas
d'accord non plus quelle est votre idée
la plus constructive en matière de
durabilité à sion pourrait-on dire du
tourisme
il n'y a pas que l'isolation parce que
c'est extrêmement pas complètement tort
dans ce sens qu'en effet il n'est
peut-être pas utile de faire des
déplacements en avion pour trois jours
de séjour jeunes 6 ou mais est-ce que
vous avez déjà imaginer ce que pouvait
être un tourisme un peu plus durable
mais de façon cohérente en respectant ce
qu'est le développement durable c'est à
dire l'équilibré entre la partie sociale
et économique et environnemental merci
monsieur direct merci
alors me fais un inscrire en ligne yvon
collin ils vont tu nous entends ils vont
colin en ligne
oui oui un jour parfait oui nous les
bons jours tentant dont cinq sur cinq
aussi bien si metella merci merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général j'ai deux questions
puisque j'avais d'autres mais vous avez
répondu dans votre excellent en propos
liminaire
d'abord concernant le rapprochement avec
la vidéo avait la chasse française de
développement
même si les deux groupes n'ont pas
complètement fusionné même pas du tout
vous avez établi depuis quelques années
un partenariat constructif et la caisse
des dépôts des 10 chaque année d'efforts
importants pour l'aide au développement
est ce que la crise actuelle monsieur le
directeur remettrait en cause cet
engagement de la caisse des dépôts en
direction de leur aide au développement
autre question vous avez sans doute pris
connaissance monsieur le directeur d'un
article paru dans le média le 18 mai
concernant sous le titre d'ailleurs
lecointe le mawlid et à cet article
si vous l'avez lu certainement tire à
boulet rouge sur le google france et qui
est devenu d'ailleurs depuis depuis
janvier le moteur de recherche officiel
de l'administration française et dans
cet article il est dit que ce google
france et est loin d'être un moteur de
recherche indépendant et que ses
résultats seraient tirées principalement
par le moteur de recherche bing de
microsoft
la dynamique a dit nul mais aussi l'inde
6 en procéder à des audits sur cointe
qui révèle un certain nombre de failles
techniques mais aussi de gestion alors
monsieur le directeur la caisse des
dépôts est très engagé cette start up
est ce que vous pouvez répondre aux
critiques qui sont faites par cet
article je vous remercie monsieur le
directeur
merci du vent merci beaucoup et on va
tester à distance aussi avec elisabeth
lamure la présidente de la délégation
aux entreprises elisabeth super bien
merci
de petits madame la présidente monsieur
le directeur général j'aurai quelques
questions en lien avec l'action
économique des régions les régions qu un
rôle important pour la sortie de crise
s'ils tentaient évidemment qu'elles ont
suffisamment de moyens financiers
également de moyens juridiques
c'est ce que nous a indiqué françois
bonneau que nous avons récemment
auditionné et peut-être pourriez-vous
nous dire
selon vous quel serait le cadre
juridique adapté en dehors bien sûr des
moyens financiers l'or pour aider les
entreprises notamment celles qui sont
convoités par des entreprises étrangères
certains avancent l'idée que les régions
puissent émettre des obligations
convertibles pour conforter les fonds
propres de certaines entreprises
ce que vous pouvez nous dire ce que vous
en pensez vous avez évoqué dans votre
propos les fonds abondé par la banque
des territoires et les régions qui
s'appelle en essence résilience et c est
ce que vous pensez qu'une déclinaison
départementale de ce dispositif régional
serait pertinente
j'ai compris que c'était le cas pour la
route marne mais peut-être seulement
expérimental ensuite sur le plan des
formations la cdc gestionnaire de mon
compte formation
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire comment
vous travaillez avec les régions et les
autres financeurs de la formation
professionnelle pour flécher les
abondements en droits complémentaires
vers des formations qu'ils soient bien
en adéquation avec les besoins des
entreprises dans nos territoires
et puis enfin vous avez évoqué également
la couverture numérique
on voit bien que la crise accentue le
besoin d'une concurrence efficiente sur
le marché de gros des télécoms
d'entreprise de manière à accélérer la
numérisation des pme des tp dans le
territoire est ce que vous envisagez en
particulier via la banque des
territoires d'intervenir dans ce domaine
spécifique et comment je vous remercie
merci moi j'ai philippe dallier philippe
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général je vous parlais de
logement et du logement social en
particulier à j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'entretenir avec vos collaborateurs il
ya à peu près un mois sur le sujet il
n'était pas à l'époque très inquiet bon
c'était peut-être un peu tôt pour
mesurer effectivement l'impact de cette
crise je veux ce matin que vous n'êtes
pas beaucoup plus alarmiste
alors je m'en réjouis d'un côté mais mon
caractère plutôt pessimiste fait quand
même me demandez si vous n'êtes pas trop
optimistes alors côté promotion
immobilière alors vous dites que sur les
quarante mille logements offerts par ces
habitats 32000 ont déjà été entre
guillemets réservé on peut voir ça
positivement mais on peut aussi voir
cela comme le signale une certaine
inquiétude chez ceux qui ont recours aux
services de la caisse
on nous dit d'un autre côté que les
coûts de construction pourra être
augmentée d'une vingtaine de pourcent
alors j'ose espérer que le chiffre n'est
pas le bon mais si c'était le cas on
voit bien que ça va peser de manière
extrêmement importante sur le secteur
aussi bien que sur la promotion que pour
les bailleurs sociaux dans une période
où l'étau tard pendant ce peut-être à
remonter légèrement pour les
particuliers on voit bien qu'on risque
de planter tout simplement le secteur de
la promotion immobilière cotée bailleurs
sociaux
il ya une vraie interrogation sur les
impayés de loyer alors là aussi il est
peut-être également trop tôt pour voir
ce qui pourrait se passer dans mon
département
certains bailleurs avaient déjà annoncé
qu'il ferait une remise gracieuse de
deux mois de loyer et puis s'apercevant
le lendemain qu'effectivement il n'en
avait pas les moyens et ont fait machine
arrière
alors faire des remises gracieuses vous
constatez des impayés je sais pas ce qui
est le mieux au bout du compte on voit
bien que il risque de se poser un vrai
problème chez les bailleurs et notamment
les bailleurs qui accueille les
populations les plus en difficulté alors
tous ces bailleurs sociaux avait déjà dû
encaisser les conséquences des décisions
du gouvernement sur la rls et sert à des
dispositifs ont été mis en place mais on
voit bien qu'à moyen terme
quand même un impact et puis au bout du
compte on fait que de rajouter de la
dette sur de la dette et d'étaler dans
le temps si jamais on traverse et je le
crains quand même une nouvelle passe
assez difficile qu'est ce qui va nous
rester comme solution parce qu'il ne
faut pas oublier non plus et je termine
là dessus que les collectivités locales
vont être impactés et je pense que on a
du mal à le mesurer aujourd'hui mais si
je regarde ça à l'aune de ma commune
moyenne dans le 93
ces deux millions de pertes entre les
nouvelles dépenses et les pertes sur
2019 ces deux millions à se retrouver
avec une épargne honnête qui va être
réduite à zéro en a en une année et donc
nous demande est effectivement de
construire de finances et du logement
social d'accueillir de la population et
donc quand vous additionnez tous là
monsieur le directeur général j'ai quand
même du mal à être jeu pâtir optimiste
mais modérément pessimiste je suis quand
même relativement inquiet donc voilà je
voulais simplement vous faire part de
mon ressentiment mon sentiment sur le
sujet sophie 24 et noisy merci madame la
présidente monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur général vous
l'avez dit donc la caisse des dépôts est
un opérateur majeur du plan france très
très haut débit et nous l'avons tous
constaté cette crise du duc o vida
encore davantage fait ressentir la
fracture numérique à la fois
territoriale et sociale avec plus de
plus de 13 millions de personnes qui
sont éloignés de l'usaj du numérique
donc il est absolument essentiel c'est
un an des enjeux de cette relance de
reprendre rapidement les investissements
tant sur les réseaux que sur la
digitalisation à la fois des entreprises
comme le dit ma collègue elisabeth
lamure mais aussi de l'administration
territoriale et des villes et vous
parlez pas besoin de tout à l'heure de
votre implication dans les smart cities
et notamment au travers peut-être de
l'action coeur de ville donc est-ce que
vous avez identifié des des soutiens des
appuis à l'ensemble de ses acteurs des
territoires des collectivités qui vont
s'engager dans la numéro me numérisation
dont on a besoin pour faciliter l'accès
de nos concitoyens aux services publics
aussi bien des grandes villes dirais que
des plus petites villes puisqu'on voit
aussi tout l'enjeu autour du commerce en
ligne avec cet opéra l'opération de
restructuration des coeurs de ville ces
collectivités aussi un réel besoin
d'accompagnement et d'énergie en cyber
sécurité
aujourd'hui il ya un véritable manque
l'absence d'accompagnement sur ces
sujets là donc qu'envisagez-vous et
envisagez-vous plus pratiquement devenir
aussi accompagner les réseaux puisqu'on
l'a vu lors du dernier plf l'état
accompagne insuffisamment notamment les
rip dans les territoires dont qu'avez
vous prévu sur ces points-là et enfin
dernière petite question pour rebondir
sur ce que vient de dire mon collègue
dans le cadre du soutien aux
collectivités puisque la banque des
territoires c'est d'abord la banque des
collectivités
envisagez vous des actions de jeu stable
de près plus solidaire vis-à-vis de ces
collectivités qui ont des manques à
gagner lourd donc c'est pas des
problèmes de trésorerie
c'est vraiment de problèmes structurels
de capacités de financement qui vont
s'aggraver dans les mois et
malheureusement certainement les années
à venir
il ya bien sûr les communes touristiques
il ya mais sur les problématiques
diverses qui ont été évoqués il ya aussi
les communes forestières et la fibre la
sensibilité toute particulière de la
caisse des dépôts vis-à-vis des des du
patrimoine forestier envisagez vous de
soutenir ces communes notamment une de
l'est de la france qui subissent des
pertes depuis plusieurs années et qui
aujourd'hui ont un déficit de recettes
de fonctionnement de plus de 40 %
parfois merci merci antoine faivre
si monsieur le président madame la
présidente monsieur directeur général
j'avais moi même une question sur les
ados tourisme mais effectivement entre
temps dans votre intervention vous avez
évoquer les sujets comme d'autres
collègues je suis je me permets
d'insister sur le fait qu'il faudra
effectivement une bonne communication
auprès des acteurs de la filière
concernée pour qu'ils puissent avoir
accès dans les meilleurs délais à tous
les dispositifs que que vous avez évoqué
jeu revenir également sur l'épargné vous
avez rappelé les montants suite ailleurs
ou aux chiffres que vous aviez annoncé
début avril et à ce que vous avez
indiqué tout à l'heure les 7,4 milliards
sur la période d'avril cette épargne
souhaite effectivement que par une
épargne puisse dormir et qui reste
justement au disponibles au soutien à
l'activité et aux logements je partage l
heureux ceux entre parenthèses la
vigilance exprimé par philippe dallier
il ya quelques instants
j'ai envie de vous demander par rapport
à toute cette épargne pas comment est-ce
que vous avez des pistes et des conseils
à donner pour justement comment on
pourrait relancer la consommation des
ménages les volumes sont importants
on a bien vu que la phase de
déconfinement à la réouverture des
boutiques n'a pas entraîné une frénésie
d'achats
on parle chez les constructeurs
automobiles une éventuelle prime à
nouveau est ce que vous avez justement
dépister qu'est ce qui vous paraît
souhaitable pour pour relancer la
consommation à ce niveau merci si
antoine marie noëlle lienemann marie
noëlle madame la ministre
voilà oui bonjour excusez moi j'ai des
preuves de son parcours voilà simplement
vous dire que je partage pour une large
part le diagnostic fait par philippe
d'avis concernant notamment le logement
social
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur les impayés
par ailleurs des prélèvements qui ont
amené à endetter davantage plutôt qu'à
aider réellement et ma première question
va être interrogé sur les garanties
d'emprunt puisque même si on nous dit
que
les empreintes de la garantie d'emprunt
ne compte pas dans le calcul de la dette
des collectivités
la plupart des agences de notation le
fond les collectivités ont donc du mal
sans compter l'énorme impact de la du
retard des municipales donc est ce que
la caisse des dépôts pourrait pas
assouplir son dispositif de garantie
d'emprunt
l quelles solutions à voir parce
qu'aujourd'hui même s'il ya des
opérations qui sont reportés ghana qui
était en cours qui sont bloqués par
cette histoire de garantie d'emprunt
deuxième sujet on a dans les bloquages
beaucoup d'opérations qui seraient 10
ans en nous et fès et même si la caisse
des dépôts qui est l'acteur principal
parce qu'avec des prêts longue durée
pour ses fesses on se rend compte quand
même qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
traînaient les est ce que vous pouvez
je vous enverrai une note là dessus sur
la manière de rendre plus rapide
les décisions de stabiliser les critères
et surtout prendre en compte le fait que
les opérateurs se sur logement social
accession coopérative ou autres sont des
opérateurs qui ne sont pas instable avec
leur solidité permet d'alléger un
certain nombre de parachute et d'airbags
qui sont demandés ensuite le taux le
prêt du tout évidemment le taux des
prêts pardo est évidemment quelque chose
d'un est quelque chose d'essentiel et
donc je voulais vous demander si vous ne
pensez pas que l'on pouvait avoir une
baisse temporaire des marges des taux du
livret a
comment d'ailleurs voyez vous
l'évolution des taux du livret a
peut-on passer maintenant vers les prêts
à taux fixe plus nombreux pour les
offres des organismes de logements
sociaux
parce que devant l'incertitude de
l'évolution des taux d'intérêts tout
cela est assez paralysant et tout
particulièrement la cristallisation de
taux fixe pour le ps elle a des
locations différer la location
attributions parce que la peur de tout
un certain bloquent le passage de la
réalisation ps et là par les accédants
et pourtant ce pays cela se fait souvent
dans des territoires
justement les petites entreprises
auraient bien besoin de travail
aujourd'hui voilà j'aurais évidemment
plein de trucs à vous demander une
simple que la gt parce que je considère
comme étant le plus urgent est
déterminant merci monsieur le président
a en tout cas
alors si marie noëlle christine lagarde
en ligne
christine oui oui oui merci monsieur le
président j'aurais voulu revenir sur le
sujet des investissements d'avenir pour
lequel vous avez dit avoir des échanges
avec le secrétaire général à
l'investissement
et j'aurais voulu savoir si vous aviez
notamment évoqué alors après même si
c'est pas de votre ressort directement
mais une certaine réallocation entre la
nature des aides puisque le sénat à
plusieurs reprises a critiqué le fait
que dans l' enveloppe de 10 milliards il
avait finalement assez peu d'argent
frais de subventions ce qui pourrait
peut-être être la chose la plus utile
aujourd'hui pour aider les startups les
jeunes pousses notre économie c'est
merci viviane artigalas oui merci madame
la présidente monsieur le directeur
général
moi je voudrais insister sur les propos
de michel raison le développement
durable et le particulièrement le
tourisme durable il ne faut pas oublier
qu'il repose sur trois piliers qui
doivent être équilibrés l'économie le
social et l'environnemental je crois que
c'est important dans ces temps où on
peut aller vers des extrêmes de ne pas
l'oublier je remercier michel raison de
l'avoir bien rappelé selon le dossier de
presse du comité interministériel du
tourisme de jeudi dernier le fonds
tourisme social investissement verra ses
capacités d'intervention augmenté de 225
à 22 125 millions d'euros et les
critères d'éligibilité seront assouplies
en 2019 ce fonds avait mobilisé près de
125 millions d'euros cédant que
d'efforts de 100 millions d'euros
supplémentaires qui seront confie
consenti cette année et je m'en félicite
mais là c'est l'orientation concrètes
qui figurent dans ce dossier
c'est concerne le renforcement des
opérateurs pouvez vous revenir
précisément sur les orientations qui
seront retenus pour les concours
financiers apportés par le fonds sera
illimité aux organismes du tourisme
social viendra-t-il aussi en aide aux
structures les plus en difficulté
sera-t-il concentrer sur l'aide à
l'investissement ou sur d'autres aides
je vous remercie michel can wait
merci monsieur le président je voulais
moi aussi dans le prolongement de de
viviane artigalas évoquer le fond
tourisme puisque sur le sujet du
développement touristique on voit bien
que les acteurs sont très inquiet qu'une
part prépondérante des interventions
soit fait en prêt compte tenu de la
situation de recettes particulièrement
faible voire inexistante donc la
capacité d'un capacité à rembourser mais
j'ai vu dans le projet de d'intervention
du groupe caisse des dépôts qu'il y
avait un apport en fonds propres tout à
fait significatif est ce que des projets
ont déjà été identifiés comme
susceptibles d'être financés dans ce que
vous avez en portefeuille et qui
pourraient orienter un tout petit peu le
la manière dont ces fonds pourraient
être utilisés donc si vous pouviez nous
apporter quelques quelques exemples cela
pourrait nous donner quelques
indications plus précises
et puis est-ce que à l'instar de cette
intervention en fonds propres pour le
secteur touristique qui est importante
est ce que la caisse des dépôts envisage
d'autres interventions en fonds propres
je pense aussi en particulier pardon
pour ce qui concerne la souveraineté
numérique de la france
yvon collin évoqué tout à l'heure le cas
de kong mais nous avons beaucoup à faire
pour cette souveraineté numérique en
france et en europe d'ailleurs pour ne
plus être dépendant des chinois ou des
américains est ce que la caisse des
dépôts à des projets en la matière
dominique estrosi sassone qui doit être
en ligne depuis nice munich
oui vous m'entendez
en teintant merci bonjour madame la
présidente monsieur le président
monsieur le directeur général en ne pas
être redondant avec un certain nombre de
questions qui vous ont déjà posé domaine
du logement
je voudrais vous poser des questions qui
concernent plus des structures
d'hébergement d'hébergement social des
foyers pour jeunes des résidences
universitaires qu'il s'agisse de
propriétaire ou de gestionnaire ces
structures aujourd'hui sont en grande
difficulté pour honorer leurs échéances
consécutivement à des difficultés
d'exploitation et de tensions de
trésorerie puisqu'elles ne génère plus
de revenus ou parce que tout simplement
le gestionnaire délégué ne parvient plus
à verser ces redevances aux bailleurs et
je voudrais savoir si la bande des
territoires a prévu des aménagements
spécifiques pour ces structures
toujours dans le domaine de
l'hébergement et urgences avec la crise
qui a fait apparaître un besoin
important de mise à l'abri de logements
accompagnés et surtout de vos
structuration des hébergements
collectifs d'urgence ou des foyers de
travailleurs migrants pour les rendre
demain résilient à de futures pandémies
alors comment la cdc à travers
essentiellement sa filiale un adoma
peut-elle être demain un acteur
structurant dans le moyen et le long
termes de réponse sur le plan de
financement sur le plan d'ingénierie et
sur le plan de la gestion et enfin
dernière petite question qui concerne
votre foncière tonus territoire qui donc
distingue bien les usages du bien et la
nue propriété pour produire des
logements en muzu fruits locatif social
est ce que aujourd'hui avec la crise
plus de promoteurs sollicite tonus
territoire sur des opérations qui
auraient déjà été lancé qui était prévu
en libre et qui reviendraient
aujourd'hui à prévoir des ventes en bloc
plutôt que des ventes à la découpe
merci beaucoup
merci dominique jean marc gabouty oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général la caisse des dépôts
et consignations un rôle d'acteur mais
de par la diversité des domaines dans
lesquels elle intervient vous avez aussi
je dirais une un rôle d'observation
ce que je voudrais indiquer partant du
principe qu'en général le pays pour des
raisons presque culturel est assez
performant en terme de protection et ne
l'est pas autant en termes de relance
mais de dynamisme donc après deux mois
très ralentie au niveau de l'économie et
1 re démarrage depuis quelques semaines
très très poussif les aspects financiers
sont mes entendu essentiels ils ont été
plutôt bien traités puisque on a un
dispositif au niveau au niveau national
gouvernementales et avec des relais dans
les territoires notamment au niveau des
régions qui est assez assez complet et
qui semble assez performante dès lors
qu'il s'agit de gérer les problèmes de
court terme c'est à dire les problèmes
de trésorerie de report d'échéances etc
mais la relance ne dépend pas que des
aspects financiers
on peut aussi considérer que notre pays
par rapport à d'autres pays voisins y
compris ceux qui étaient aussi touchés
que nous par cette crise sanitaire a
très fortement ralenti je dirais même à
trop ralenti la poste n'a pas bien
fonctionné de fin mars à mi avril pour
l'emploi étaient fermés les déchets prix
ne collectait plus les par exemple et
les cartonnages ce qui a mis ce qui a
failli mettre à l'arrêt insolente
d'unités de production d'emballages
destiné à l'agroalimentaire et et aux
pharmaceutiques ont crié on a eu un
niveau de ralentissement qui a été à mon
avis trop fort y compris dans les permis
de construire pourquoi at on arrêté
d'instruire les permis de construire moi
je me pose toujours
je me pose toujours la question
pourquoi n'at-on pas réussi au niveau
des yeux pétillent et des communes par
un système de délibérations à accorder
des garanties d'emprunts aux organismes
de logement social qui arrêtent des
dossiers parce que il leur manque cette
cette garantie à un moment donné dans le
processus administratif il respecte
cette cette étape donc ma question c'est
est d'avoir votre appréciation sur les
les autres freins à la relance
sachant qu'en plus le contexte est
incertain parce qu'on peut avoir sinon
une deuxième vague au moins un rebond de
de la pandémie
ce qu'ils risquent je dirais freiner
encore les ardeurs de ceux qui veulent
s'attacher à une redynamisation de
l'activité économique et la lourdeur de
certaines procédures
la rigueur maximaliste parfois
irréalistes voire inefficace de certains
de certains protocoles sans d'ailleurs
ensuite dénoncé on dit on on demande
moi je prends un exemple si vous voulez
dans une place la circulaire de monsieur
blanc caire a fait le calcul se place de
50 m² on doit pouvoir mettre quinze
élèves alors vous arrivez au niveau du
maire j'étais maire pendant 22 ans dont
je parle critiquer mes collègues
l'avaient aux yeux du maire en dur oui
bon 15 élèves et c1 mais là attention il
ya un meuble on peut pas le déplacer et
c'est bon pour être tranquille on va en
mettre 12 la directrice d'école arrivent
en disant oui mais 12 6 mois je me
déplace dans la classe et puis pour
sortir c'est compliqué au niveau des
cheminements de 15 ans finit à huit ou
dix civils et dévoilant le nom mais
concrètement sur le terrain ça se sent
ça peut se passer comme ça je ne parle
pas du débat qu'il ya au niveau de la
restauration si on doit avoir quatre
mètres carrés je dirais pour deux
personnes d'un couple qui dorment
ensemble la nuit mais qui devront
consommer 8 mètres carrés d'un
restaurant à midi ils iront pas au
restaurant c'est bien évident donc non
mais
ça paraît anecdotique si vous voulez
mais toute une partie de la relance
économique est basé sur des petits
détails de cette est basé sur des petits
détails de cette de cette nature donc
quelle quelle vision avez-vous de ses
autres freins qui ne sont pas des freins
financiers parce que je pense que sur
l'aspect financier on a pris le problème
par par le bon bout
par contre on risque de plomber une
relance économique par je dirais un
manque d'agilité et de souplesse dans
les dents dans les procédures qui
doivent encourager nos concitoyens et
des entreprises à revenir à un niveau
d'activité qui qui nous permettra de
sortir du je dirais de deux
éventuellement d'éviter une crise trop
grave parce que la crise grave elle
arrivera nombre de chômeurs ce sera en
supplémentaire ce sera en quelques
millions supplémentaires 3 ou 4
probablement à l'automne merci merci
beaucoup et line renaud garabédian parle
evelyne oui merci mama président
monsieur directeur général vous avez
déclaré travailler sur un projet de
plateforme permettant aux professionnels
du tourisme de se réapproprier les
données clients et ainsi de remédier à
la crise du secteur par les plateformes
étrangères
s'agit-il de créer un mot king français
ou bien s'agit-il d'une simple ouverture
des données touristiques qui permettent
aux acteurs d'innover comme cela est
actuellement le cas pour les données de
mobilité dans le cadre de la riante de
la loi d'orientation des mobilités je
souhaiterais également vous interroger
sur cette mesure cette discrète mais non
moins importante du plan tourisme à
savoir l'appel à projets à destination
des entreprises et starter pour inventer
le tourisme de demain
enfin vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure si
j'ai pas bien compris la possibilité
pour les hôteliers de favoriser les
prêts notamment par la réalisation de
travaux s'inscrivant dans une
perspective de développement durable
s'agit-il d'un argument pour faciliter
les demandes de prêts garantis par
l'état actuellement mis en place ou bien
s'agit-il d'un autre dispositif avec une
autre demande au quel cas faut-il
solliciter la banque
la bpi ou bien la caisse des dépôts
merci de vos réponses ne plus personne
très bien alors je continue roland
courteau s'est passé rolland est
toujours là roland en l'emportant dans
des wii en tentant roland merci oui j'ai
lu que de problèmes de connexion et je
n'ai pas eu à trident à toutes les
interventions pas donné d'ailleurs qui
mon intervention n'est présente qu'à
voronezh la filière de la construction
qu'il s'agisse de la rénovation des
locaux mais distincts ou des bâtiments
ne représente à la fois l'impératif
climatique
près d'un tiers des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre est un levier pour
relancer l'emploi
la rénovation énergétique et ans
titre très riche à l'emploi et au moment
où l'on parle de relance immédiate de
l'activité
cela me paraît nécessaire de le
souligner ce qui est attendu c'est un
plan massif d'incitation à la rénovation
thermique de l'ensemble des logements
80-90 constant des chantiers sont à
l'arrêt ce qui est attendu c'est un
complément aux prêts consentis par la
caisse des dépôts aux organismes hlm
pour aider au financement des travaux de
rénovation aux scènes du parc social
d'un logement et enfin il y a
l'important gisement d'économies
d'énergie à travers la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments publics et là
aussi il y à un gisement d'activité et
d'emploi pour une relance durable alors
deux questions quelle est la part qu'un
pack peut être celle de la caisse des
dépôts sur ces différents points
une question plus générale vous
paraît-il nécessaire d'aller vers une
conditionnalité des aides en portions
les considérations énergétiques ou
environnementale de manière à orienter
les comportements d'investissement vous
remercie merci j'ai froch mais non ville
ensuite alain chatillon franck mée
ville la meuse
franck alors on va passer alain
chatillon s'il est la plus au sud alors
eu alain coupé ça y est on n'a pas coupé
tu es là contentant merci merci monsieur
le directeur général pour des éléments
que vous nous avez fourni et ne peut que
saluer me féliciter pour le travail que
vous accomplissez cyclo équipe
moi j'avais deux petites questions
posées c'est sur le coeur de ville et
territoires des lustres sur territoire
des russes crient les choses ont été
bien lancé
il va falloir les accompagner avec le
redémarrage et j'espère que cela
conduira d'un intérêt tout particulier
pour les communes qui sont dans le rural
ou dans les périodes pour le coeur
devine sur les 222 coeur de ville les
actions ont été menées et vous les
accompagnez sans difficulté n'avait été
question sénat
voici quelques mois d'élargir l'action
coeur de ville à d'autres nos qualités
un petit peu plus petit c'est à dire des
centres-villes centre bourg ce qui me
paraît important pour relancer tout le
petit commerce dans le rural et le
périurbain et donc je vais savoir si
vous envisagiez cette solution pour
élargir le nombre de coeurs de vie merci
daniel grémillet daniel plus sûr qu'il
est par là passerait il m'a demandé la
parole daniel grémillet voilà j'ai moi
aussi un problème de connexion file
daniel entente je parlais voilà merci
madame raison mais ce directeur général
merci aussi de deux questions la
première concernant la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes
au niveau économique qui a des
répercussions énormes sur l'énergie aie
ma première question est ce que vous
pensez ce que ce contexte
économique sera une opportunité ou une
difficulté pour encourager les
investissements
nous allons vers l'atteinte de la
neutralité carbone
quand on est lé prix de l'énergie
fossile le retour à l'investissement
d'investissements lourds effectivement
peut conduire à faire des choix qu'ils
n'iraient pas dans ce sens donc c'est ma
première question
la deuxième question vous avez beaucoup
évoqué l'accompagnement au niveau de la
transition écologique et énergétique et
je voudrais prolonger la question de ma
collègue anne catherine loisier
aujourd'hui donc elle a parlé des
communes forestières qui des communes
qui avec son impact et par rapport à la
crise forestière et sanitaires ma
question plus globale
aujourd'hui notre territoire est en
train de vivre une pandémie sur la santé
dvd arbres sans précédent que ce soit en
feu nu ou en résineux est ce que vous
pensez imaginable que dans vos ambitions
de maintien de la biodiversité et de la
transition écologique énergétique est
l'atteinte neutralité carbone ou la
forêt joue en essentiel un
investissement majeur sur la
replantation la halle en accompagnant
les communes forestières
dernière remarque je voulais vous faire
passer est pas une remarque c'est vous
dire effectivement et étant élus de la
région camp-est je préside le comité
résistance dans le département des
vosges votre accompagnement est vraiment
important et c'est important parce que
c'est des petites affaires c'est des
choses très simples dans nos territoires
qu'on essaye de sauver et choix qu'il
faut aussi souligner il ya des grands
projets et à les entreprises moyennes
et puis elle est petite initiative qui
j'ai dis toujours ce qui est petit peu
devenir grand donc merci pour votre
accompagnement territoriales merci
beaucoup daniel j'en ai fini monsieur le
président la curiosité des commissaires
de la commission à faire écho alors
monsieur le directeur général on va vous
laisser répondre évidemment vous allez
pouvoir peut-être regrouper un certain
nombre de questions dans vos réponses
pour tenter de ne pas abuser
et de la patience de toutes et tous mais
on a besoin d'entendre vos réponses oui
merci de vos encouragements
monsieur le président bon elle
facilement de courir les sujets alors
pour commencer par les questions de you
rapporteur général sur les fonds
d'épargné en fait on peut assouplir un
sérum de processus et élargir légèrement
les cibles d'ailleurs on a initié des
choses nouvelles comme les autres après
récemment où les et du prêt et puis on a
tout un tas de processus comme le peuple
et les éco prêts qui sont 1 0% où on est
on est quand même limité par une règle
de des fonds d'épargné qui est
importante c'est celle que les prêts des
pompes des fonds des panneaux doivent
être garantis et une question a été
posée d'ailleurs est-ce qu'on pouvait
assouplir ou non cette garantie
je vais vous faire une réponse directe
mais qui n'est que mon avis je pense que
ce serait une pente dangereuse parce que
la question des fonds d'épargné
c'est un système les parrainent des
français est utilisé pour financer le
logement social et les collectivités
locales
et ces prêts sont garantis par les
collectivités locales et donc on est
dans un système qui est extrêmement
sécurisé en est en réalité système sur
lequel historiquement il est
incroyablement peu de défauts et donc ce
système sécurisé tout le monde sachant
que si les collectivités locales ou les
organismes de logement social ont des
difficultés j'y reviendrai il ya des
opérateurs comme la caisse des dépôts
par exemple qui y pourvoit et mettre en
place les aides nécessaires
donc je pense que il sera risqué cette
occasion de sortir de ce système ce qui
veut dire effectivement pour répondre à
des questions vous avez posé d'autres
composés que c'est compliqué d'utiliser
les fonds d'épargné pour le financement
des entreprises
d'autant que c'est le rôle qui est dans
le groupe
le rôle
de bpi france alors j'ai pas vérifié ce
point ça me surprendrait que ce soit
passer directement par les fonds
d'épargné a pu passer par la section
générale ou parce qu'ils allaient
devenir bpi france parce
qu'effectivement bpi france dont la
caisse détient 50% financer des
entreprises et continue à faire mais des
fonds des parrains de jeu je pense que
cette règle est réellement très très
très ancienne qu'on est face à sa
n'imite pas notre capacité à faire mais
on fait part par d'autres canaux alors
solide et évidemment beaucoup de respect
pour ses idées de nouveaux fonds nouveau
système mais parle mais il me semble
qu'à un moment où il ya un consensus
pour juger que l'épargné un peu
surabondante
moi je serais plutôt dans l'idée
d'utiliser cette épargne
et puis éventuellement d'inciter les
français à consommer plutôt que d'ouvrir
des nouveaux fondée par nous donner vos
produits qui risquerait d'augmenter
encore plus cette épargne est d'ailleurs
comment favoriser la consommation alors
il peut y avoir des mesures techniques
qui relève du gouvernement et je m'y
aventurer pas mais c'est essentiellement
une question de confiance
d'abord une question d'accès à la
consommation quand on verra les
restaurants les gens pourront consommer
dans les restaurants et les boutiques
ont sont ouvertes depuis le 11 mai et ça
peut favoriser sa mémé par ailleurs il
ya une question de confiance alors sur
les questions ouvertes par notamment le
sénateur raison sur l'aménagement du
territoire et sur le 80 c'est réellement
une préoccupation est réellement une
préoccupation constante depuis nous
avons créé la bande de territoire et je
dirais qu'il ya une réponse déjà qui est
la déconcentration et la
décentralisation de la décision à la
caisse des dépôts et nous avons donné
des délégations aux directeurs régionaux
et et leurs équipes pour qu'ils puissent
prendre des décisions à leur niveau sans
qu'ils aient intervention du siège qui
sur des décisions de cas là tout le
respect que j'ai pour tous mes collègues
n'apporte pas forcément grand chose et
les des objectifs
alors je parle de ce qui est sous ma
responsabilité ouais
les objectifs qui sont données à nos
équipes sont pour partie des objectifs
en volume pour contribuer au financement
de l'économie et aussi en nombre
d'opérations pour qu' il ya eu une
incitation domination public est pas une
nation commerciale une incitation à
financer des petits projets dans les
territoires plus éloignés ou d'ailleurs
dans les métropoles peu importe mais
nous souhaitons absolument ne pas être
l'institution qui financent d'abord les
grandes institutions les grandes
associations les grandes entreprises qui
trouvent plus facilement à se financer
même si nous faisons aussi et on est
très très attentif à ce que le maillage
fait vraiment le plus près du terrain
d'où l'idée que les fonds sans aller
trop dans le détail mais les fonds du
plan tourisme il ya beaucoup de fonds
qui sont dédiés vers des fonds vers les
petites entreprises et vous m'avez
d'ailleurs interrogé sur le fond au
tourisme social innovation madame
artigalas il ya un goût un groupe de
travail qui qui est en place c'est que
vous y participer pour élargir les
objectifs de ce fonds et dans les fonds
qui sont alimentés qui vont être
alimenté par des pays france ou par la
caisse on est vraiment très attentif à
ce que ça touche le tissu associatif et
les petits opérateurs
c'est quelque chose de très important
alors après le côté développement
durable et tourisme durable ça irrigue
nos politiques ce n'est pas une
conditionnalité
c'est assez compliqué comme ça en ce
moment on va évidemment inciter les
opérateurs
mais si quelqu'un qui a une petite
échoppe dans telle ou telle ville ou tel
ou tel bourg a besoin de financements
aux besoins de fonds propres
et ben si c'est pas pour faire de la
rénovation thermique on va quand même
lui accorder ce prêt parce que la
priorité c'est de sauver ces entreprises
bien sûr donc il ya pas de
conditionnalité
ils vont comme à cannes où nous
interroge sur leur rapprochement avec
l'afd qu'on appelle l'alliance parce que
c'est pas rapprochement institutionnel
ça continue à fonctionner d'ailleurs
quand je me rends en afrique c'est avec
vincent riou et où n'envisage de
déplacement en métropole ensemble pour
bien marquer l'articulation entre les
deux maisons
notre engagement ne faiblit pas et dire
c'est pour ça que je me suis rendu comme
je le dis en côte d'ivoire récemment au
sénégal un peu avant pour une réunion
des caisses des dépôts africaine
à sur lequel nous nous jouons évidemment
un rôle un rôle important et je crois
utile sujet qui n'a rien à voir mais que
je traite quand même sur pointes wii
points ce n'est pas parfait et
s'appuient effectivement il ya une
relation d'ailleurs avec microsoft qui
est assumé et qui est connue mais quand
c'est un moteur de recherche qui
respecte les personnes et qui ne
collecte pas les données individuelles
et donc nous pensons que il ya un espace
pour un moteur de recherche de ce type
nous avons opéré parce que dans les
start up et une phase de développement
qui demande un certain type
d'entrepreneur et puis après il faut
stabiliser et renforcer donc nous avons
opéré à certains changements de
management qui se sont fait de la façon
la plus consensuelle possible pour
renforcer ce moteur et nous jouons notre
rôle d'actionnaire et donc moi moi j'ai
confiance dans le développement de cette
entité c'est un secteur difficile
l'idée qu'on présente une alternative
européenne ou géant américain c'est
quand même une ambition et moi je suis
très fier qu'on soutient de celle là
même si tout n'est pas gagné
alors ensuite question posée par
certains d'entre vous les régions et les
départements
là on est dans dans les compétences des
uns et des autres et je ne m'aventurerai
pas là dedans mais je sais qu'il ya
débat
voilà et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
les fonds résistance résilience
renaissance sont faits avec les régions
sur l'implication éventuelle des
départements c'est une question qui
regarde l'état
nous nous travaillons et avec les
régions et avec les départements et nous
n'avons pas vraiment à prendre parti
dans dans ce débat ce qui est important
c'est que en tout cas les décisions
soient prises en relation avec les
collectivités locales
et c'est vraiment je pense une des
raisons du succès de cette opération qui
va être un grand succès opérationnels
vue de mon fauteuil est toujours dans la
relation avec les régions
le développement de mon compte formation
sur lequel il ya eu effectivement
continu des compétences en matière de
formation des régions quelques
difficultés puis en plus on avait une
difficulté technique sur le la façon
dont les dotations des régions pouvaient
transit et c'est vraiment un sujet de
finances publiques
disons assez complexe faisaient un
effort de mémoire je vous retrouverai le
sujet me rabat le sujet a été traité et
donc moi je pense que cette question qui
cette question est derrière nous alors
sur le sénateur d'allier sur le logement
social si je vous ai paru pas inquiète
c'est que je me suis mal exprimé
je je ne perçois pas à ce stade de
difficultés et du chez les opérateurs du
logement social donc sur l'immobilier en
général
il faudra très attentifs et sur le
logement social il faudra être très
attentifs parce qu'évidemment la
difficulté dans laquelle malheureusement
discuter croissante on peut le craindre
dans lesquels nos concitoyens on se
trouvait peut peser sur la rentrée des
loyers ce que vous dites sur
l'augmentation des coûts de construction
correspond également à notre analyse
aujourd'hui la distance situation
sociale et la réduction des équipes ça
ne va pas dans le sens d'une réduction
des coûts de construction
donc il faudra qu'on soit extrêmement
attentifs donc nous on n'est ni
pessimiste ni optimiste on est engagé
mais je sais que vous l'êtes aussi et
donc on est très en soutien du secteur
du logement social ou veut étendre ce
soutien au delà du logement social dans
les quarante mille logements prévus par
céder ses habitats il ya du logement
intermédiaire et il y à du logement
libre parce que tout ça c'est aussi une
continuité il faut que les personnes qui
sortent du logement social y en a chaque
année puissent trouver des logements et
qu'il faut soutenir le secteur dans son
ensemble ça demanderait une attention
extrême
la loi est lent
a permis à semble de rapprochement comme
vous le savez entre des acteurs qui sont
pas forcément des rapprochements qui
sont ce qu'ils sont les rapprochements
qui sont pas nécessairement des fusions
ça peut passer par des sociétés d'action
les sacs ça peut passer par différents
liens cdc habitat un projet très
ambitieux pour continuer à soutenir le
secteur
dans la période qui vient et on mettra
les fonds propres qui sont nécessaires
pour que nous jouions notre rôle
d'autres grandes plateformes je pense à
action logement vous aussi opéré de
façon à soutenir des acteurs plus
modestes dans le respect de leur
autonomie et de leur stratégie propre
on n'est pas dans le secteur du
capitalisme de wall street on est dans
le secteur du logement social donc c'est
évidemment ça n'a rien à voir mais il ya
quand même des sujets de fonds propres
il ya des sujets de soutien et donc je
pense que chacun doit jouer son rôle et
la caisse avec les fonds d'épargné le
jouera pour pour soutenir les uns les
autres et puis veiller à maintenir le
rythme de construction ccsl et de
rénovation et de rénovation thermique
notamment sur la rénovation thermique
moi je suis un grand soutien de la
rénovation thermique dans le logement
social parce que c'est bon pour la
planète et c'est bon pour les charges
ça réduit les factures quand même et les
loyers pour les collectivités locales
aussi il faut inciter à le faire même si
c'est plus compliqué c'est très
compliqué dans le privé alors les fonds
départ ne peuvent pas y contribuer parce
que là on est dans le privé ce que je
viens de dire tout à l'heure
s'appliquent également
on a train de réfléchir au travers des
réseaux bancaires si on peut permettre
des systèmes en place mais là il faut
faire travailler ensemble le locataire
ou le propriétaire avec les artisans et
avec un mécanisme qui doit avoir un
maillage extrêmement fin parce que ces
logements par le jugement et là je dois
reconnaître qu'on n'a pas trouvé encore
la bonne formule et le fait qu'on y
réfléchisse voilà on va trouver mais on
n'y est pas
on n'y est pas encore justement sur le
numérique et le soutien de la
numérisation
je dirais qu'il ya plusieurs sujets il
ya d'abord le développement du très haut
débit
et là franchement la banque td
territoire fait le job où on a investi
560 millions de capital dans plus de 50
rip 760 millions de prêts et on
n'envisage plus pour pouvoir les trouver
dans les chiffres mais desservir 10
millions de locaux à l'horizon 2025
donc la couverture des zones qui
n'étaient pas couvertes par les grands
opérateurs on s'en occupe et ça avance
vite
avant la crise on met un place 5500
ligne par jour par jour alors ça s'est
ralenti on va veiller à ce que ça se
ralentisse pas trop longtemps parce que
c'est décisif parce que parler de
numérique si les personnes peut parler
de télémédecine comme en faisaient tout
à l'heure si les personnes ne peuvent
pas se connecter
franchement on va pas aller très loin
autre facteur les maisons france
services les espaces rend service et
leur nouveau nom qui va être une façon
d'amener le digital dans les régions et
puis la banque des territoires au
travers de ses plateformes et notamment
de la plateforme digitale de la bande y
était et toi met en place tout un tas
d'outils numériques
je je je je note effectivement la
demande d'accompagnement éventuellement
des collectivités locales dans leur
numérisation
c'est probablement des outils sur lequel
au travers de nous dit conseil qui je le
rappelle sont gratuits où on peut
accompagner les collectivités peut-être
c'est un service qu'on n'a pas assez mis
en avant donc je donne pas comme idée
qu'on pourrait développer la suite de
cette de ce dialogue que nous avons
voilà pour cette audition d'eric lombard
le directeur général de la caisse des
dépôts et consignations il a assuré aux
sénateurs que son institution ferait
tout pour soutenir l'économie pendant
cette crise du corona virus il les a
également informé que les français
avaient beaucoup épargné pendant ces
deux mois de confinement avec une
collecte du livret a historiquement
haute
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi continuer à vous
informer sur ces crises sanitaires sur
notre site internet publicsenat.fr je
vous souhaite une très bonne journée sur
public sénat
mais
[Musique]